hello everyone Diego Torres in Tunisia I
hail from Mexico I'm a software engineer
at 2 Sigma you will learn in a second
how that is related to this talk or why
it's relevant as you saw the the title
of the talk is cleaning optimizing and
windowing pandas with number if you were
playing they paying very close attention
you will see that the title of the talk
changed last night at around midnight
the other title is still relevant but I
think this one is better before we go
any further just like this talk is not
about bears or cleaning their enclosures
this talk this talk is also not
financial advice all right so this is
the agenda we're gonna be going over
first I will talk about the goals of the
project that I'm discussing then I'll
talk about the team then we'll do a
quick introduction to windowing
operations what I mean when I say when
doing operations then we will I will
tell you the history of how these were
implemented in chandus then I'll talk
about how they're currently implemented
in pandas and what are some issues that
that in current implementation has then
the meat of the talk is how to refactor
them for flexibility performance and
maintainability then how would this look
with number that's in the title and I
guess one detail I'm giving away already
is that the current implementation uses
this thing called scythe on and I will
tell you what that is to implement
window ops impact in pandas this project
proposes using a different library
number so we will discuss what we
think the advantages of using number
oversight on our so like I said here are
the project goals
we're trying to make pandas windowing
operations more maintainable more
flexible and faster of course none of
this work is yet merged we're in fact
still discussing it so if you want to
join the discussion if you are very
invested in this topic you have opinion
so you think you have seen things that
could make this better
we invite you to please join the
conversation on that github issue all
right next up is the team so these are
the people involved in this project
first I would like to mention Matt Roche
he is a panda scorer there he is helping
us do basically all of the coding and
everyone else on the team is just
happily sitting back reviewing and
discussing the code then we have Jeffery
back up and the score them they sitting
back there the main change panda so he
has been very instrumental in this work
Phil cloud helped us write the spec and
review and discuss some of the work and
then that's me that's a four year old
picture of me this is what I look like
on github I used to everyone's github
picture so I thought it was only fair to
use mine as well alright so like I said
before I work for 2 Sigma 2 Sigma is a
tech company in the financial services
space like main many finance companies
we really like data specifically we like
time series data and as a consequence
we're very interested in windowing
operations this is why this project is
close to our heart and this is why we're
working with the pandas core devs on
this project
all right so a very quick basic intro to
window operations
so first let's discuss what I think is
the most basic case a rolling mean
rolling mean the rolling concept you can
sort of think of it as a skateboard
moving over a vector so that's the
skateboard - imagine you have a vector
and this is the input vector and it's
just one two three one five six seven
eight say that you get the rolling mean
of this input vector with a window size
of three my window size of three here I
mean three observations are being
considered when you do the mean so when
you want to calculate the first element
of the output vector since you only have
one observation so far in your rolling
window the rolling window is the green
box then you only average that one
element so the the mean of one it's just
one the mean of 1 & 2 is 1.5 and the
main 93 is simply 2 now this is where it
gets interesting we're calculating the
mean of the window size of 3 so when we
go on to the next element the green box
won't just expand it will shrink on the
other side so we have sort of the one on
the right we leave out the one on the
left we still have the same average
because the same element that came up
also came in on the other side and then
we can keep going I want to at this
point hinted you at a possible
optimization for calculating the rolling
mean I will in fact go back to this case
notice that we were calculating the mean
of one two three and then a number came
in one and a number abandoned the
calculation of also one so you can
imagine an implementation of the rolling
mean instead of calculating the mean of
all those three numbers
every time you move the window you can
simply keep a running sum and then when
you shut the window to the right you add
the element that came in you subtract
the element that just left the window
and now you can divide by the total
which of course you're also keeping a
running counter and that gives you the
rolling mean and that lets you do way
less operations because you only have to
do operations over than over the size of
the window over how many elements use
live in and out or there are many other
kinds of window operations rolling mean
is the thing that sort of often people
call them sliding windows it's just the
green box sliding over the vector and
then doing an operation over the
elements inside that green box
there's also expanding windows here I
guess the metaphor I'm using is that an
expanding window is an ocean wave and
this is expanding max so this time
instead of calculating the mean over the
green box we're getting the maximum so
when the green box explains we just find
the new maximum there's a graphic sir in
my slide all right so so far we have
been looking at window operations with a
fixed window size when I say fixed
window size I mean the size of the green
box is always a constant amount of
observations but this is not necessarily
what you want if you are all familiar
with pandas you will know that and the
series or data frames often have an
index and that index gives you an
indication as to the ordering of the
elements in your serious or or data
frame so sometimes you want to express
the window size in terms of units of the
index so here don't get confused it's no
longer input/output both are the input
data now on the top row I have the index
and assume this is an index by they and
then on the second row I have the data
so this means for example that this is
an observation for the first day
these two are observations for the
second day and so on and so forth so
this time when you do a rolling me by
time say that we're doing three days and
we're calculating the rolling mean for
this for over here this time you will
have way more than three elements on the
green box this time the green box spans
from day two to three to day four so we
have six observations even though we're
doing three days this is what inside the
pandas codebase is known as a variable
with window then there are many more
complex cases the one I want to talk
about is exponentially weighted rolling
average people usually don't call it
rolling average that's not what it's
called in pandas you will usually refer
to that the moving average or EEMA for
its initials I will be calling it EEMA
terima is similar to a moving average
except that before you calculate the
average you wait your things you wait
the observations and you weight them by
an exponentially decaying weight so the
weight of this observation is twice as
much as the weight of this observation
which is twice as much the weight of
this observation and EEMA just the green
box keeps sliding or growing sort of
depending on who you ask
anyways so that's a quick run through of
window operations whether they look like
in pandas or whether they live you've
surely seen them in the methods that are
available in the data frame and the
series there dot rolling dot ewm and dot
expanding so note that this API is
already hinting us at how these
operations should be implemented there
are rolling window operations
there are evil um notice that there is
no a there it's not exponentially
weighted moving average it's just
exponentially weighted moving something
and then there's expanding and this
suggests that you can have a rolling
mean exponentially weighted moving
variance or mean or an expanding minimum
or maximum for example and another thing
I wanted to mention is these operations
have sort of grown in the pandas code
within the pandas code base fairly quick
in March 2016
rolling ewm and expanding were first
introduced as methods and series and
data frames before that rolling mean was
implemented directly by a method called
rolling mean and this was sort of not a
very scalable approach because it would
end up with rolling underscore mean
rolling on their score variants rolling
on their score eight and then you would
have had to have a rolling apply for
users to be able to bring in their own
functions so this was not sustainable
this is why the methods were created
also in May 2016 just one minor version
above in the versioning scheme rolling
and resample we're added to group by
then in December merge Assaf was
introduced I want really the Scott
discuss much of merge Assaf just know
that it is very similar to a rolling
join and if you're an expert on this
topic that might be interesting to think
about and rolling started accepting time
series offsets the more complicated ones
in 2016 as well so before you could only
do a rolling mean of three days when
this feature came out you could do a
rolling mean of three custom business
days and then you could implement your
own definition of what a business
is this of course of great interest to
the finance industry and then 2018
rolling an expanding gained a row
argument that added a significant amount
of complexity to the API their argument
lets you pass in
a when you do a rolling apply for
example it lets a function that you're
calling take in an umpire e as opposed
to a panda series and this gives you
more control over what exactly that what
exactly is being applied anyways so with
quick turnaround time came some bugs
so everything I'll be showing you now is
the change log off and that's overtime
so this I believe was from the first
from the version right after rolling and
expanding and blah Blau were added as
methods and she sort of kept piling on
notice how the last one is really long
so for the next few slides I would like
to walk you through why why we think in
retrospect this happened and what we
think can be done to fix this issue so
before I show you actual code know that
the code that I will show you in a
second is actually not Python code it's
psyphon code sight on is it has a syntax
that are very very similar to Python
except that you add a few bits here and
there was notably you had type
annotations to it and in exchange it
gives you native level performance
scythe on is a compiled language you can
compile it in advance turn it into
machine code therefore it is really fast
when you call to sight on code the
Python interpreter can release the Gil
whence item code is being this gives you
much better multi-threading
characteristics as well and you can also
call Python code from cyclone code so
your size and code even though it's
running in in native machine code it can
say okay now I want to call out back to
this function in the Python interpreter
this is very important because this is
how user-defined functions are
implemented when you say rolling apply
the rolling part is
is a for-loop running inside site on but
scythe on has to call back to python to
run the function that you provided which
is written in Python and this is at the
core of the performance issue that I'm
trying to hint that is very important we
want everything running in native
machine code we don't want this sort of
context switching which slows us down
all right so finally we have some code
this is a snippet of code from rolling
apply notice that here it's called roll
generic generic means it could be you
could be applying any function notice
first the type annotations some of the
type annotations are not very lumen
ating notice that this parameter called
func is being passed and this parameter
parameter func is the use of the find
function and it is defined as an object
because in psiphon you cannot type
annotate a python function is used to
spy on types it is not necessarily
deterministic in the type of in the type
that it returns so you cannot annotate
it then here you'll see it's item code
is actually it actually looks a lot like
python so this does give you the great
advantage of writing Python like code
with great performance and this gives
you a reasonably beginner-friendly code
base as well scythe on is not that hard
to write it looks like Python and that's
the whole point of the project that it
looks like Python that's a user-defined
functions now here's a code for rolling
mean again notice that it looks a lot
like Python notice also that it releases
the Geo
so in this critical section of code
where it says with no Gil that code
inside does not have the global
interpreter lock and the interpreter can
go do something else
while this code is running
like I said it's not Python you will see
this is a Python syntax error this is
like SC idiom for passing things by
reference or you're passing pointers do
those things this makes it code more
efficient rather than passing a copy so
between these two slides and just this
same code is moving to the right I kind
of want to assume out on this code I
want to show you what is above and
around it so right above this code
you'll see that this section is inside
an an else clause and right above it of
course is the if part of the statement
and you will see this branching if is
variable then do this
else do that and you can sort of see
that the code is not completely
different it's actually kind of similar
it's not straightforward how you would
generalize for both sides it seems it's
it sort of sounds like the variable size
should be able to handle a fixed width
window so it seems like this is a more
general version of the thing on the
right so why is this happening you will
find an explanation right above this
code in a comment and it reads as this
for performance we are going to iterate
fixed windows separately it makes the
code more complex as we have to cats but
it's faster so your there's a clear
trade-off going on here there is a
trade-off between maintainability in one
hand and performance on the other hand
and this code up there for update for
performance and I think this is part
this is this can sort of explain why we
have seen bugs arise in this way within
these features means inability has sort
of become
more difficult as new features were
added particularly because many of these
features were sort of added as like
extra sections of code that were never
really consolidated with the rest here's
the code for rolling apply again except
this time I assumed out so I think
before I showed you what's hit the
bottom part or maybe the middle part now
I was a bottom part it was a for loop
this time i zoomed out I still didn't
show you some parts but really what I
want you to notice here is the same
if-else happens again you get the same
branch the same repetition and this was
done clearly for the same reasons there
is a trade-off to be made between
performance and maintainability and
performance one all right so our project
concerned itself with trying to at the
same time clean up this code but also
make it more flexible more maintainable
so that we can plug into this code and
implement our own functionality up to
Sigma but we also wanted to make sure
that this code is easier to maintain
both for Jeff and all the other
maintainer x' who owned it and we think
that this is contributing back to the
community decreased potential of bugs
and these features in the future as well
as the pluggable API we want to make
will also be available to the community
so early on in the project we gave
ourselves some requirements we wanted to
make the code for windowing operations
easier to read we wanted to have
pluggable support of custom window
operations so say that rolling I don't
know as an example say that rolling
standard deviation is not implemented a
user should be able to a power user
should be able to implement their own
rolling standard deviation and be able
to take advantage of all the performance
gains that the panda's code base is
getting from running machine native
machine code so one day user to be able
to drop down to that level if they find
it necessary to get the performance they
need
we also wanted to keep all existing
tests we know that pandas is a tool
relied upon by many many folks and so we
found it unacceptable to break any
existing tests because that would
probably break userspace code and of
course for the same reason we wanted to
keep the existing API so we don't we
didn't want users to have to go and
change their code after this project and
we also decided we wanted to avoid all
large performance regressions we think
that in most places we will have
performance improvements but we have
identified some spots where maybe large
performance improvements won't be
possible and maybe a few small ones
where we might have small regressions we
think the regressions are acceptable as
long as they are outweighed by by
greater maintainability gains so how do
you actually write these these window
operations so that they're generalizable
so that if you are missing just one
small component if pandas already has a
code to implement a rolling thing over a
time over a time series and you're just
missing the last spot the dot apply your
dot apply is not optimized how do you
implement that so this came from the
very beginning it's in our specification
we wanted to separate the concerns of
way of applying windowing windowing
operations into three components an
indexer an aggregator and a kernel the
indexer all it does is it calculates the
bounds of each window so for the green
box that we were seeing sliding the
index are simply the sides where the
green box starts and where the green box
is the aggregator it's a little bit hard
to explain so I'll explain the kernel
first the kernel simply knows how to
apply a mathematical operation for
example we would expect a mean
to exist and the mean kernel knows how
to compute the average of a set of
knives the aggregator is sort of the
intermediary between the indexer and the
kernel it knows how to for each change
in the window bounds I don't call the
kernel in an intelligent way that
optimizes over the kind of window that
you're using this is a bit confusing so
let's just use an example I think that
will clarify things a lot so this is how
we think stretch rolling means should be
structured so we have a rolling in mixer
and a rolling indexer just knows how to
apply a rolling window we have a
subtractive wall aggregator a
subtractive aggregator basically applies
an optimization that I was talking about
earlier before to make a calculation of
a rolling window much faster and then
there's a mean kernel the mean kernel
just knows how to compute the mean and
this is what they do get window bounce
if you're just doing a rolling index say
the window bounce simply the begins just
always moves by the size of the window
and the other end also moves by the size
of the window so it looks like a
skateboard rolling over your vector then
let's talk about the kernel first the
colonel knows how to add a number to the
current sum to the current running sum
and it keeps count of how many numbers
are currently in your window and then
the aggregator is the smart smart thing
that realizes that things are coming
into scope and are coming out of scope
of the window and then it just says ok
for the things that went out of scope in
the window let's call invert and invert
is the thing that just subtracts them
from the rolling sum and then for the
things that just joined the window that
just entered the box you add them to the
running sum and then the very last but
important thing that the mean kernel has
to implement is the finalize method and
in finalize for a mean you just divide
by suit the song
by the by the count of elements and
voila you have your average and of
course this works for any windowing
operation you can think of you can
implement the rolling Mac and expanding
Mac's by using the expanding indexer a
subtractive all aggregator because you
can apply the same optimization of
adding things notice that's invert will
never be called here because the left
side is always at the beginning and then
the max eternal I just want to emphasize
again this max kernel that we will use
in expanding max would be the same max
kernel that we use in a rolling max so
you can share code for a user-defined
expanding operation you can use the same
expanding indexer this time you have to
use a different aggregator you don't
know if the user function is smart
enough to subtract elements or to just
add a specific element so the apply
aggregator would be a very simple
aggregator that simply computes the
cause the kernel for the whole window
without any optimization and then we
have a UVF kernel which is really just a
callable and it doesn't have to do
anything smart because we use the dom
aggregator that doesn't expect anything
from you or as a power user could
implement the methods invert and add and
then say hey I don't want your puppy
apply aggregator I implemented the
protocol that satisfies the requirement
so they're subtractive all aggregator so
please give me that aggregator instead
and that's how you implement a more
efficient operation and the same goes
for EEMA you would have a rolling index
setter with a NEMA a greater the Magra
Gator with know how to compute the
weights and then it just caused a mean
Colonel in the you in the same way as
the regular subtract total aggregator
and this is why we're very interested in
this a to Sigma to Sigma we will be able
to implement or only index a aggregator
and kernel and plug it plug them into
pandas and do the exact operations that
we want to do that we think are so
special all right
so I haven't mentioned number and the
whole talk and I only have like ten
minutes left so let's start talking
about number who here is familiar with
number can we do a quick show of hands
okay great so I'm glad I'm explaining
with number yes number is a just-in-time
compiler for Python so it generates
machine code for given some Python code
the core difference that it has with
scythe on which is what I've been
showing you so far is that although code
is compiled in both cases in number code
is compiled at runtime so in scythe on
you have to compile the code when you
ship your package to your users you have
to do it before that number can take any
code at runtime compile it and run it
and none at at runtime without
restarting the interpreter without
nothing so this is how you get compile
or just-in-time compile some Python code
you have the engine decorator and now
number goes and it turns this code into
machine code
Noma can also do this for a class so
with the Jib class decorator you can
also generate machine code for all of
that class and this is why we think
Namba is a great fit for this project we
can have the JIT class decorator to our
aggregator or investor and our kernel
and users power users of course would be
able to do this at runtime themselves if
they wanted so in a notebook they would
be able to write their own kernel you'd
compile it and then have pandas run it
for them and this time this time they
would get machine level performance for
the entire cycle of calling your window
operation
there will be no step where machine code
is calling in to Python code like with
the old rolling apply instead number
functions calling each other never have
to abandon the compiled space they never
have to get back the interpreter look
can all happen in machine code space all
right so of course there's reasons why
siphon has been used all this time I do
want to say site owned existed before
but there are other reasons so let's
talk about the trade-offs here what are
numbers the strengths what are its
weaknesses so I think one very strong
side of number is that it takes native
Python so all valid number code is valid
Python code number code is easy to debug
in most cases assuming you did not do
anything that upsets the JIT compiler
but instead there is a bug in the code I
wrote like a human mistake you can
simply remove the JIT decorator and now
you're debugging Python code and you can
use PDB or any of the other tools that
you know and love to the above your
Python code
another strength is that users can write
their own UDF and compile it all at
runtime so they don't have to pre
compile a library to be able to use it
with a number version of windowing
operations in pandas so what are the
weaknesses nobody still maturing it's
been around for a few years now
but it's not quite at the same place in
the development cycle as syphon is for
example also pandas already depends on
site on it does not depend on number
today so being able to do with this work
with number would imply convincing all
of the core developers that this that
adding this dependency is a good idea
and if you do something that offsets the
JIT compiler in number I'm not gonna say
that no but number issues are always
easy to debug you will run into cases
where you get a mysterious stack trace
from number particularly that power user
that is trying to write their own
user-defined function it does something
very smart they might get a compilation
issue a typing error most likely and it
might be it might get a little bit
mysterious so that's pretty much it
that's a summary of the project like I
said in the very beginning all this work
is still in discussion it is not yet in
mainstream pandas we're talking to core
thieves we're talking to the community
to see whether a number the pendency
would be well accepted or whether they
think that maybe we can implement the
exact same thing but just use scythe on
so we would still clean up the code but
maybe not open as many use cases of
compiling code wallets while the
interpreter is running you know there
are some cases where number is not
perfect yet and compiling site and code
that is much more performant it's
sometimes easier but we think many of
these issues can be ironed out with the
pandas team and the number team working
together through so we think that number
is quite ready or
if not almost ready for app and us to
use it extensively another consideration
another possibility is to make number
optional so implement everything in
sight on and if a user brings in a
number function then we can try to use
it and call it from scythe on and still
allowed the user to never read machine
code space but not bring number as a
hard dependency of the pandas project
yeah that's it
I'll give some time for Q&A also here is
the license for the little red bug that
I used I am required to show this by
your license yeah thank you all we have
five minutes for Q&A so pandas has very
few dependency so adding another one is
not a small deal it means all of the
users all of all pandas users will have
to bring in a new dependency into their
environments there's also been some
discussion a lot we're not sure if
number has great support for all the
architectures that's that scythe on
supports so that might be a
consideration as well I guess a passing
a number function you're gonna make
assumptions around so number let's you
decide whether you want to turn off the
gel or not and it sort of leaves it up
to you
so you're not gonna have the wave well
the decorator lets you specify the width
no Jill would go away
whether that crater might have
yes
so it is hard to measure like how much
effect it has because when you're doing
a context switch you're moving from
something that is really fast scythe on
to something that's generally much much
lower so it's actually just the fact
that you're moving to something slower
that slow thing dominates the time one
thing that you will find out is that if
we're a rolling apply in pandas s is you
just threw away the site and
implementation and implemented it in
Python
you wouldn't see any difference because
the slope I thumb code that you provided
it's probably what dominates the
complexity
well if there's no Oh question so the
thing you called the rolling method on
is a panda series you know there is a
raw argument unrolling and expanding if
you pass bra and then you pass in a
function so you say rolling rod true
apply then the function that you pass in
apply instead of seeing a series which
is the case when Rho is false
when Rho is true it will see a array
cool well thank you all so much I'll
hang around if there's no question
[Applause]